hi I'm John my name is Billy tisha hi
and I'm Melissa and today we're
transforming into clowns I have been
doing my makeup routine for about five
years I've been doing this particular
clown routine for forty five years I'm
starting at nineteen and I've been a
professional clown for over the last
decade let's get started at first when
I'm doing my makeup I always go from the
lightest to the dark so that way I can
cover up over those light colors of have
any mistakes as I'm going along and I'm
gonna be using my favorite paint brush
today
I'm also gonna start with white just a
little bit I always use grease paint
when I'm doing my makeup because it can
be set with powder and it can last for a
really long time I can also take like a
spit to the face or a pie to the face
and this grease paint won't go anywhere
so if you are a pro clown and you're not
using grease paint you better get on it
my clown blouse that I wear there's a
recreation of the same blast that I made
45 years ago so I've kept most of my
look pretty standard for years and years
and years I have about six clown looks
but the one I'm doing today is the
moneymaker not like job like I know this
isn't a competition but I'm always kind
of feeling competitive but I do it like
I do a lot of like kids parties and you
don't have much time like you're like
driving to and fro on a Saturday you
have like six parties in one day so I
like usual thing is just like a ton of
blush to be like you bloom and then it's
like in the outfit wear it like really
pops so I'm putting my white on here
because they call white the light in a
can so everywhere that I put this white
it's just really gonna pick up any light
that is hitting my face and I am a
circus clown at heart so all of my
makeup is a little bit exaggerated so
that way you can see it all the way from
the nose
leads of the arena how did you first get
into Colleen you know I used to go to
the circus when I was a kid and
absolutely loved it and then that kind
of transitioned it to gymnastics where I
learned how to do
slaps trips and falls and then next
thing you know I was applying to clown
school you went to clown school yeah
that's great oh my god but in clown
school I learned things like
professional makeup swimming and gag
writing and it really gave me all the
important tools that I needed to give me
a jump start in my career this is crazy
I'm not used to really cueing this and
people watching me I always have cameras
online really no I started clown with
commedia dell'arte which is like Italian
mask loudly very very I cried a lot it's
real hard it's actually super super hard
but it's be all like physical comedy and
there's all these different stock
characters you wear masks you don't have
your face to like express emotion so
everything is through your body and then
I've done um kind of like idiot stuff
recently so basically you're a
professional idiot yeah yeah same clown
nose gives a lot of information about
clowns I'll actually have a professional
clown nose that's glued on to my nose
and when you see a clown that does the
clown knows what makeup it's different
than someone includes a nose on it
that's one way to tell the wig is a big
deal but how clear and defined their
makeup is there are people who look like
they put on their makeup in five minutes
people who here's another way of telling
the people who have real professional
noses versus sponges if you see a clown
with a sponge nose again I'm not judging
it's fine if you are I think that people
should judge that's so not me a clown to
me
is a mirror that reflects itself back on
to society that's and clowns give people
the opportunity to laugh at themselves
and it gives me the opportunity to laugh
at Who I am
because I can be a knucklehead sometimes
and that is real life
it's funny when you hear it and through
its frustration of trying to achieve
this one task that's where the humor
lives and it's almost funnier we don't
want to see the clown win we want to see
them fail and rejoice in your New York
rescue ya raise your hand if you yeah
yeah a good place for the clown to be is
in honk yes - the rookie clown veteran
clown show would probably be called si
si clowns
how about star skin really what part of
I'm delightful isn't clear because of
the stereotypes of scary clowns some of
the adjustments I've made I would see a
little bit less makeup and also just
knowing your audience knowing like what
am i walking into I also think it's
fashionable fashionable to be scared of
clowns and there's camaraderie and
people somebody will say I'm scared of
clowns and then next thing you know
somebody else like you know what I am -
and next thing you know they're bullying
up on the clown which kind of sucks
because at the end of the day the job of
the clown is to
bring joy and laughter I went to a party
and the kid was like really obsessed
with the Little Mermaid and I can sing
pretty well John I'm not trying to be
cocky I'm not trended to my own no I'm a
pretty good singer and I like saying
part of your world cuz it's like little
girl and she just started like sobbing
like she was so like taken aback by it
and it like it was like so sweet I feel
like I'll never forget that moment and
like her mom was crying and they were
just like so happy and I was like wow
you should be proud that you make
children cry tears of joy tears of joy
tears of sorrow here's a joy so I put
blue on my eyelids it looks like you do
I do too yeah the same reason as me what
is your reason to make my blue of my
eyes off me to be - yeah like it our got
our peepers yeah all right I think guys
when I have more intense clown makeup I
feel my commitment level just naturally
Rises and it's easier to just be a clown
you know what I mean like cuz you're not
yourself yes absolutely yeah so it is
that's good you know if you have the
time and the resources not everybody is
as rich as John here with his
prosthetics I can't afford this I'm
working a kids party for 50 bucks a pop
I think it has like really clean
beautiful makeup and he knows where to
place the lines on his face to make him
look really scary but like as a clown
addict I really appreciate it makeup but
you got glue it's in a glass case get it
close up of that they can't afford that
I could have put a new roof on my house
or bought these to iron you own a house
I've never watched it it just kind of
hurts my heart it hurts my heart
I love Stephen King but it kind of hurts
my heart that that's kind of I feel like
that's kind of been like the genesis of
like what scary clown is now I don't do
full-time
with Halloween costumes it was like ooh
everything's sexy the sexy girl you know
and now clowns it's like Oh everything's
scary you know and it's like what's next
like ponies and kitties like are they
gonna be scary are they gonna come
they're already sexy I definitely have
also modified so growing up my mom owned
a party stores and then she also was a
clown I remember she had this like clown
jumpsuit that she would wear and she had
like a crazy red wig like she was like
the classic clown and I remember even as
the kid being like mom you look like I
never was like into it but and so then
when I started doing it you know she was
like trying to get me to do the way that
she did it and I was like honestly kids
are afraid of it I love that it is a
scary clown whereas a lot of people who
are scared of clowns are scared of
somebody who is just wearing a clown
mask or somebody who is dressed as a
clown whereas it is a clown who is scary
and I think that that really adds to the
element of the fear with it because of
that film there is less clown work on TV
less of commercials for clowns clown is
for joy and bringing laughter and
happiness and that's the complete
opposite the evil clown and those people
that are dressing up as clowns just to
scare people it all changed in 1986 when
the book it came out before that I had
never had anyone told me they were
afraid of class oh really okay so that
actually is really interesting and VHS
changed it because people were able to
get the horror films that they loved and
how to clown stories in it they really
were prevalent so people never used to
be afraid of you pre-1986 Wow that
actually is pretty too like the horror
films they started doing lots of for
homes with clowns and now why do you
think they
because it's kind of funny it's like
evil it's like it's yeah I play I can
with two fingers right now by simply
smearing this down I can be a scary
clown I think that an important part
about designing your clown face is to
not just look at somebody else's and
choose clipart to put on your face what
makes a really good clown face is when
you learn the lines of your face and you
figure out where to put the makeup so
I'm putting my eyebrows in a very
particular spot so that way when I am
raising and doing exaggerated features
these lines are going to bend and
they're gonna raise and come down really
low whereas if I put it up just an inch
further it would be right in the crease
of my forehead and they would disappear
when I was raising my forehead John he
said I do a sad clown one no but are you
sad
what part of I'm delightful isn't that
how big were the audience's they were
huge here at the Staples Center I
perform for a sold-out crowd of 20,000
people but I can also perform for just
one person - if I need to and I think
that that's an important skill of a
clown is to be able to adapt to whatever
the audience is so your clown thinks
he's a pop star but he is kind of a rock
star like performing in front of that
many people you really are I can do hair
more than make up so that definitely
like adds a lot to the clown sometimes I
don't when I did what I used when I do
full clown white oh they want a circus
I'll just glue with the latex like a
little hat on yeah it's kind of cute
with you know I don't know if you notice
I just started losing my hair I'm gonna
be cleaning this up but yeah yeah good
I'm 99% a bit simple
[Music]
hi I'm Johnny the clown and I don't want
to toot my own horn but we've had a
transformation today hi my name is clown
name and I am ready to party what no you
wanted hey everybody my name is Billy
and I am ready to clown around hi
everybody
hey y'all my name is Lizzy the clown and
I just want to say that if you want to
put clown makeup on you can do it too
everybody can alright happy birthday
[Music]